now let me ask you about if I'm not
being too forward but I just wonder how
your life's going you in a relationship
right now are you
you're not relationships no that's a you
know big area to carve out that you're
not good at human interaction not really
that's that's what happens yeah yeah
well what kind of man are you looking
for what are you like in a man I mean
right right really so a tall sweet guy
you like what's your is there a height
limit like if the guy's like over seven
feet tall or eight feet tall just as
tall as they come really okay that's so
interesting
well you know high school everybody
thought there was this other kid that
was really short he was a wrestler and
they always saw us together and I just
felt like the hobbits you know when we
went out brothers and you lived in the
Shire yeah
then there was the ring and you know I
saw you the first time I think I met you
was backstage at a charity of course
they were just like a painting yeah they
didn't move that kid to that played the
piano he was a prodigy he was great I
don't remember that much oh thank you
thank you very much but I remembered
this event I'm talking to you backstage
and then I see you perform and of course
I know that you're a great singer but I
was I was kind of blown away you have an
operatic range you're fantastic singer
I'm curious what kind of exercises do
you have to do before you go out and
sing like that do you have to can you
just can you just like wake up you know
from a dead sleep and sing like that or
do you have to do a lot of things I have
to do warm-up and I mean you know I've
many times will find myself doing them
walking down the streets of New York
because I'm running to a meeting or to a
show or whatever I'm gonna sing at and
sometimes I'll go do the belting
exercise which is you just go hey you
over there hey you over there and that's
one that's it that's a singing exercise
yeah hey you over there yeah that's a
singer that's rising you're using your
diaphragm hey you over wow that wasn't
good yeah that was bad what does it do
it just gets you don't you find that
people are like coming to you when you
do that what is it nothing I'm
practicing notices in New York it's oh
yeah in this city that's gonna get you
know someone probably getting murdered
what is it again
[Applause]
you're you are a little bit in your
mouth which which there are exercises
really didn't come out right but
basically there's the exercise I made up
to help you with your fiction you mean
keep it in here is what you're saying
okay so don't use the mouth at all birds
are gonna settle on my shoulder I made
up from my town in Oklahoma and there's
a town called Chickasha City should call
Chickasha to shoot Indian tribe with
city and you say that five times real
fast because they said eh you could say
city chicks a city chicks they said a
chicks a city now you go
chicks chase no wow ok Chickasha city
chickety chickety chickety City cheapest
I can't do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I really think you'd be great on
Broadway
yes that's a show that would open and
close
thirty million dollars were lost Charles
Barkley invested
[Applause]
I never never
someday someday I'll be that there
someday I'll try those boards